ça va Ali hein he mon bébé comment tu
vas mon bébé
oui bonjour mon bébé bonjour mon bébé ça
va mon gâur qu'est-ce tu raconte hein tu
vois des marques dans le salon par terre
tu vois des petites marques parce que
quand ils mangent ils attrapent un bout
de poulet quel fois il racle un peu bon
je pas grave ça fait partie du jeu hein
c'est ils sont mignons comme tout il
ferme les yeux tu fermes les yeux à lit
il faut être en contact avec les animaux
tout doucement s'en approcher lentement
avec calme et tranquillité et vous en
faites des copains c'est tout c'est tout
bête mant quand ils ont très faim ils
vont pas manger de l'homme ils en ont
pas mangé c'est pas leur truc parce
qu'il y en a qui aiment les souris
d'autres qui aiment les rat d'autres ils
ont un goût différent les seuls animaux
qui attaquent ce sont les animaux
blessés ou les femelles qui ont des
bébés ou alors vous avez violé leur
territoire à ce momentl ils vont
tendance à vous faire partir si vous
partez pas ils vont vous rentrer dedans
mais il n'attaque pas ils défendent
quelque
chose